ok
mesdames messieurs avant tout je tiens
encore une fois a salué la nouvelle
ministre fédéral des affaires étrangères
anna lena d'abord nous étions déjà
entretenus par téléphone mais c'est
notre première rencontre en personne et
nous espérons que
cette volonté de coopération verte se
poursuivra nous avons abordé les
questions de d'actualité bilatérales et
la russie est intéressée à avoir des
relations de bon voisinage avec
la république fédérale d'allemagne dans
le respect mutuel et le respect des
intérêts des deux pays nous sommes prêts
tout à fait à
travailler dans l'optique des
de la volonté de résoudre toutes les
tous les différends qui se sont
accumulés qui a été énoncé par le
gouvernement par le nouveau gouvernement
allemand et
ce potentiel
existe il a une base solide et nous
avons
constaté
l'ats le volume des échanges entre nos
deux pays l'année dernière et par
rapport aux années
2019 et 2020 on a vu une augmentation
est donc ceci est soutenue par les
opérateurs économiques par le soutien de
l'état et nous on enregistre là une
dynamique et j'ai positive donc cette
dynamique peut se faire dans le dans un
certain nombre de domaines tout à fait
prometteur comme le climat la santé les
énergies renouvelables
notamment sur les nouvelles technologies
écologiques nous avons eu un échange de
vues sur le processus de certification
qui est en cours de l'exploitation du
gazoduc north stream 2 et c'est un
commun un projet commercial très
important qui vise qui a une portée sur
plusieurs décennies qui va dans
l'intérêt de l'allemagne et de toute
l'europe nous avons attiré l'attention
de nos collègues allemands sur le
caractère contre-productif de la
politisation de ce projet nous avons
abordé les problèmes qui se posent
aujourd'hui en allemagne pour la chaîne
arte dodge est à cet égard nous sommes
convaincus que
donc les médias russes en allemagne et
que les médias allemands en russie
doivent pouvoir travailler les moments
nous nous sommes prononcés pour la
prolongation des travaux dans le forum 2
du forum de saint pétersbourg entre nos
deux pays et la plupart des participants
de la part de l'allemagne et de la
russie sont un terreau l'aps et à la
poursuite de ses activités nous avons
parlé aussi d'un autre forum ce sont des
rencontres de postdam nous avons procédé
à un échange de vues sur un certain
nombre de preuves d'actualité nous avons
accorde une grande attention et
aux relations entre la russie
et l'union européenne mais nous avons
que elles sont un peu les otages de
l'otage de détention qui sont faites
dans la région euro atlantique et
notamment
la pression
exercée par l'otan et nous avons parlé
des initiatives qui ont été proposées
par la partie russe sur la validation de
garanties juridiques contraignantes pour
la sécurité de la russie et je rappelle
que ces garanties
nous avons été transmise par nos aux
états unis d'amérique et aux membres de
l'alliance de l'otan et nous attendons
une réponse comme cela ne nous a été
promis pour que nous puissions continuer
les discussions à ce sujet à propos de
l'ukraine nous avons bien la perception
en commun qu' il n'y a pas d'alternative
aux accords de minsk et nous avons
encore soutenu qu'il n'est pas question
de mettre la russie comme responsable de
le manque de progrès dans l'exécution
des obligations des accords de minsk
nous espérons que nos collègues
allemands pourront avoir une influence
positive sur leurs partenaires de kiev
pour qu'ils remplissent les obligations
qui sont les the et nous sommes nous
avons changé sur les perspectives de
coopération dans le cadre du format
normandie
et dans le cadre donc de ce format de
discussion à 4 en faveur de l'exécution
des dispositions de des accords de minsk
avec notamment des discussions directes
entre kiev et les autorités de donetsk
est lougansk nous avons parlé également
de la situation sur la frontière
polono biélorusse nous espérons que les
deux parties feront tous les efforts
pour résoudre cette crise par le
dialogue avec les autorités de
biélorussie nous avons abordé la
question de le dire le du potentiel de
coopération de l'hôtesse et et nous
avons aussi d'autres questions que nous
avons abordé sur tout un nombre
d'orientations ça concerne notamment la
situation au proche orient et en afrique
du nord et dans la conférence qui
qui sait les conférences y sont tenues à
berlin et à paris sur la libye et nous
sommes intéressés à ce que 1 les accords
qui ont été mis qui a été conclue soient
mises en oeuvre dans la vérité et nous
sommes prêts à donner toutes les
informations nécessaires pour que
ces efforts de résolution
politique soit trouvée
en syrie
avec l'allemagne nous avons nous
travaillons de façon active aussi sur la
mise en place de conditions
pour la reprise de
la mise en oeuvre de l'accord sur le
nucléaire
iranien
nous avons donc un thème aussi
important qui est celui de l'afghanistan
et on voit ne communauté
d'attitude ici en matière de
lutte contre la menace terroriste et la
menace des trafics de
stupéfiants mais aussi des des flux
migratoires qui en découle est avec
l'allemagne nous avons des intérêts
communs pour que la situation dans les
balkans se dé évolué de façon positive
et de même que l'allemagne nous sommes
pour que
le comité directeur pour la bosnie
herzégovine dans le cadre de l'accord
qui avait été conclu et nous sommes
intéressés à ce que
la pratique du consul soit rétablie sur
pour ce mécanisme qui est important dans
l'ensemble la discussion était très
utile elle a évidemment abordé toutes
les questions
qui sont pour l'instant
des questions qui sont des divergences
mais en tout cas cet échange de vues à a
montré que nous pouvons petit à petit
avancé et surmonter ses divergences pour
le bien de nos peuples et pour le bien
des objectifs qui sont fixés aujourd'hui
pour la communauté internationale et je
suis reconnaissant à madame la ministre
et toute sa délégation pour le travail
qui a été mené en commun je vous
remercie
il était important
[Musique]
après
le début du mai fonction je suis arrivé
ici avec en large dossier
parce que nous avons beaucoup de sujets
sur lesquels nous discutons ce dossier
est large aussi parce qu'en nombre de
sujets qui sont présents c'est un su ce
sont des sujets où il ya un grand
potentiel pour l'amélioration de nos
relations entre l'allemagne et la russie
et c'est un quelque chose d'important
pour notre maison commune européenne
nous vivons en paix ensemble depuis plus
de 70 ans nous avons l'enterrer à
développer des relations stables avec la
russie l'allemagne est une nation de
commerce nous vivons de notre échange 14
mille jeunes russes se font leurs études
en allemagne est maintenant comme dans
aucun autre pays
pour nous il est aussi est très
important que nous avons plus d'un
millier d'euros lien entre les
universités ne sont très heureux que
plus de personnes
comme dans tout autre pays apprennent la
langue allemande et cela prouve à quel
point notre potentiel conjointe dans le
domaine culturel et scientifique est
énorme en ce qui concerne le dialogue et
de saint pétersbourg nous avons des
divergences
tout de même concernant les listes des
ong allemandes et russes nous avons
signé l'accord de vienne sur le
nucléaire iranien et c'est seulement
ensemble avec la russie que nous
pourrons le faire revenir à son
fonctionnement nous avons besoin d'avoir
en progrès dans nos négociations parce
que il nous manquait de temps pour
parvenir à le faire revivre nous avons
un intérêt très fort pour me mettre à nu
que le potentiel russe dans le domaine
des sources d'énergie renouvelables nous
avons envie de développer notre
coopération en faisant passer nos
économies sur des rails
doublement durable parce que c'est la
seule manière dont on peut combattre la
crise
climatique
en augmentant le nombre des forêts la
russie pourrait apporter sa large
contribution
à la capture de co2
mais nous avons besoin également d'une
russie stable pour
assurer pour les années à venir les
fournils
livraisons de gaz en europe dont on aura
besoin hier j'ai eu des négociations ici
à moscou sur l'énergie ces négociations
ont montré à quel point le potentiel
russe est énorme dans le domaine des
hydrocarbures
vers
nous avons besoin de travailler avec la
russie pour lutter contre la crise
climatique
pour travailler au sujet de la sécurité
énergétique
et le développement durable dans ce
domaine
beaucoup des sujets dont nous avons
parlé
ont été évoqués lors de notre discussion
d'aujourd'hui
l'allemagne dépend largement du commerce
de la science des échanges nous avons un
intérêt encore plus grand à conserver
l'autre mondiale qui existe en europe
qui a des règles contraignantes pour
tout le monde et sur lesquelles tout le
monde peut reposer
il n'y aura pas de sécurité dans notre
maison commune rpn s'il n'y a pas de
règles communes
sur lesquelles tout le monde peut
compter en faisant des échanges
culturels économiques
gardant l'amitié les liens familiaux et
en soutenant les échanges entre nos pays
ces règles se sont la base le socle de
notre maison commune européenne pour
l'allemagne c'est la base de notre
existence
donc nous n'avons pas d'autre choix que
de protéger
nos règles communes même si pour nous
cela a un prix assez élevé du point de
vue économique la convention européenne
des droits de l'homme fait partie de ces
règles
tous les pays se sont engagés à
respecter les décisions de la cour des
droits de l'homme il s'agit du cas de
navalni et du cas de mémorial
la charte de l'onu l'acte final
d'helsinki et la charte de paris ce sont
tous des documents dans lesquels nous
tourner pays s'engagent à ne pas menacer
du du recours à la force depuis quelques
semaines plus de cent mille militaires
et des équipements militaires russes ont
été accumulées n'a pas loin de le cren
on ne peut pas ne pas le considérer
comme une menace sans une raison visible
depuis le moment où je suis entrée en
fonction la majorité des négociations
tournent autour
l'idée est qu'ils ne concernent pas la
coopération avec la russie
l'approfondissement de nos relations
mais qui concerne plutôt les démarches
que le lieu le groupe de sept et le
temps pourrait prendre pour lutter
contre les situations au tour de la
russie au cas où la russie appliquerez
sa menace de recourir à la force nous
n'avons pas choisi ses sujets mais nous
n'allons pas nous éloigner de cette
situation la russie a exigé des
garanties de la sécurité cela a été
souligné encore une fois nous sommes
prêts à mener un dialogue sérieux
concernant sa non accord mutuel et les
démarches qui vont renforcer notre
sécurité commune qui vont
renforcer la sécurité des gens à
bucarest à berlin à saint pétersbourg à
riga
nous avons déjà commencé à discuter des
moyens de renforcer la sécurité ensemble
les négociations dans le cadre de
l'essai et du conseil russie otan ont
servi à notre avis comme le premier pas
utile le cadre de ce dialogue lors de la
toute première réunion
qui s'est tenue
récemment
toutes les tous les problèmes ont pas pu
être résolu en l'espace de quelques
heures cela n'a étonné personne mais à
notre avis il est important de remplir
de contenu concret le processus normand
pour faire en sorte qu'on puisse
progresser vers la mise en oeuvre des
accords de minsk ce serait une
contribution au renforcement de la
sécurité européenne
et la sécurité pour tous le monde hier à
kiev est aujourd'hui ici à moscou
j'ai discuté de ces démarches nous avons
réfléchi sur les propositions mutuelle
et discuter sur le pot si la possibilité
du lancement de ce processus à tous les
niveaux je me réjouis du fait que
concernant les accords de minsk et le
format normandie tout le monde a rappelé
son engagement à ces processus là et
nous avons cette compréhension que nous
allons travailler dans ce cadre là pour
pouvoir préparer la réunion commune
chère collègue monsieur lavrov au nom du
gouvernement fédéral et au nom de mes
compatriotes
avant de commencer cette réunion
gbg fait rendu l'hommage à la tombe du
soldat inconnu
je ressens de la honte et de l'attitude
solennelle envers les souffrances que
nous avons causés au peuple de l'union
soviétique rien ne peut
pour apporter une contribution à la
hauteur de ce qui a été fait
l'essentiel c'est d'avoir cette
gratitude au peuple qui ont voulu se
réconcilier avec nous
nous n'avons pas un engagement plus
important que de protéger nos peuples de
la guerre et de la violence je suis
persuadé que on peut le faire via des
négociations réussies
ensemble qu'ils ne sont pas opposés
qui ne posent pas les uns aux autres et
j'espère qu'aujourd'hui cette journée
sera le début d'un échange ouvert comme
il devrait l'être
maintenant je donne la parole au journal
sight
bonjour merci ma question et pour les
deux parties l'allemagne a joué depuis
longtemps le rôle important concernant
le dialogue en russie dans le cadre de
l'ue
à des moments où personne ne pourrait
plus négocier avec la russie l'allemagne
le faisait ce qui était souvent
critiquer pour le nouveau gouvernement
de l'allemagne voyez vous un rôle
particulier concernant cette position de
leader dans l'une le monsieur lavrov
pour vous la question suivante
l'allemagne se dit prête à avoir un
dialogue et
en même temps en disant que s'il ya une
escalade du conflit avec l'ukraine il y
aura des conséquences graves
quelles conséquences les plus graves
dans menacé le gouvernement russe ont
été discutées
aujourd'hui
le dialogue ne pourrait être réussie
qu'au cas où nous serons autour de la
même table de négociation donc pour moi
il est très important avec tous les
acteurs avec tous les partenaires de
l'union européenne dans le cadre de
l'otan tout comme dans le cadre du g7 de
faire tout pour que dans la situation
actuelle nous puissions revenir à la
table de négociation moi en tant que
ministre des affaires étrangères de
l'allemagne je voudrais apporter ma
contribution
à cette cause ces derniers mois j'ai
fait presque rien à part ça j'ai
travaillé sur la désescalade j'ai mené
des négociations donc voilà pourquoi
hier j'étais qu'il y avait aujourd'hui
je suis à moscou et nos négociations
vont se poursuivre encore dans l'esprit
de
de la possible de revenir au format
normandie
j'ai pas compris complètement la
question
vous avez dit que l'allemagne ne
menacerait la russie et que quelles
seraient les conséquences est ce que
vous pourriez répéter s'il vous plaît
l'allemagne souligne lors de toutes les
négociations et des formats qui elle est
prête à dialoguer avec la russie en dix
ans en même temps qu'il y aura des
conséquences graves si la russie
poursuit sa désescalade son escalade de
boufflers avec l'ukraine est question
concernant les conséquences les plus
graves dans le gouvernement menace avez
vous discuté des possibles conséquences
lors de vos négociations
nous avons parlé en détail de ce qui se
passe réellement en ukraine et autour
d'elle et concrètement ce qui se passe
est avant tout ce qui se passe
en matière de sabotage par le régime de
kiev à l'égard des accords de minsk et
sur la base les textes des accords de
means nous avons montré la nécessité de
cesser ce
sabotage et de s'en tenir strictement à
ce qui est stipulé dans le texte et de
commencer à j'ai su réagir sur cette
base
sur les
doubles ou triples interprétation je
sais pas de quoi il s'agit nous avons
également expliqué que cette escalade
qui émane des propos de certains nombre
de responsables politiques occidentaux
avec la présence de nos troupes sur
notre propre territoire et la poursuite
des manoeuvres militaires qui vise à
perfectionner l'aptitude au combat et
nous avons expliqué que ne pouvait pas
accepter des exigences vis-à-vis de nos
troupes
qui sont sur notre propre territoire et
d'ailleurs quand on nous a dit
de faire retourner comme blondy
l'américain nos unités dans leurs cases
and en même temps l'otan dit que ce qui
se
produit sur le territoire de l'otan
la venue de troupes depuis
l'occident les déplacements de troupes
sen ne concerne personne si ce n'est le
temps donc là on a une présence de deux
poids deux mesures
alors ces menaces de l'allemagne je peux
pas
prévoir quelles vont être les mesures
prises par le gouvernement allemand dans
telle ou telle situation nous ne donnons
aucun
motif pouvant susciter
un conflit nous ne demandons qu'une
seule chose c'est que ce qui a été
convenu soit respectée strict
heureusement je le répète encore une
fois il s'agit des accords de minsk y
sont sabotées par les le régime de kiev
et la question de l' architecture de
sécurité en europe est la question que
nous avons examiné avec les états unis
et l'otan s'appuie sur la base solide
des documents qui ont été adoptées au
plus haut niveau notamment par le sommet
de l'osce et à istanbul en 2019 et
astana en 2010 où son formuler
clairement
oui chaque pays a le droit de choisir
son alliance militaire mais il est
indiqué que chaque pays doit assurer sa
sécurité de façon à ne pas créer une
menace pour d'autres pays et nous avons
demandé à nos collègues allemands et de
même que nous avons demandé aux
américains de nous expliquer comment ils
vont
respecter concrètement cette clause dans
la pratique nous espérons donc que ce
cette discussion se poursuivra
la question est grave et
perdre du temps pour résoudre cette
question
n'est pas positif donc nous ne menaçons
personne mais nous entendons des menaces
à notre adresse et cela
j'espère que ce ne sont que des émotions
mais en tout cas cela on voit s'agiter
le camp occidentaux nous allons juger
sur la base de mesures concrètes et en
fonction des mesures qui sont prises
par nos partenaires nous définirons
notre modes d'action
différents le projet de certains disent
qu'il ne s'agit que d'un projet
économique
a quelque chose à voir avec la situation
l'ukrainienne d'autres ainsi ce
qui doit faire partie d'un nouveau
projet de sanctions le gouvernement
allemand at il une position consolidée
et unique sur ce projet et si oui quelle
est cette position merci
oui dans notre accord de coalition nous
avons souligné que les projets
d'infrastructures dont
justement tous les projets
d'infrastructures énergétiques et y
compris north stream 2 il y à cette loi
européenne on voit c'était l'esprit de
ces
lois tout comme les lettres de se
doivent à présent à la procédure a été
suspendue et à différents niveaux notre
gouvernement
insiste que si l'énergie est utilisée
comme une arme ce sera des cons ça aura
des conséquences
appropriées y compris dans le domaine de
ce gazoduc
reuters je vous donne la parole
merci beaucoup rétorque
ma question il pour les deux ministres
après vos négociations est il probable
que le format normandie
aura une réunion au niveau des ministres
des affaires étrangères pourriez-vous
dire des dates
étant donné le conflit y at-il en sens
d'impliquer dans ce format les états
unis
pour l'instant
nous sommes en train de voir notre
première réunion personnel nous avons
évoqué mais beaucoup de questions nous
allons poursuivre les discussions de ces
questions pendant notre déjeuner
en ce qui concerne les faits et la
réalisation des accords de minsk nous
avons des approches différentes donc il
est important de poursuivre les
négociations
les accords de minsk
ont été atteints dans le cadre du format
normandie il est donc important
de revenir à la table de négociation
dans le cadre de ce format nous les
ministres des affaires étrangères nous
avons c'est le bilan préliminaire de
notre réunion nous allons faire tout
pour commencer les pavés recettes
notre position est bien connu pour nous
c'est important c'est de jupe c'est pas
qu'on se rencontrer mais pourquoi
s'il s'agit de se rencontrer simplement
pour que le président vienne ce qui est
une nouvelle fois que à son initiative
un groupe de dirigeants respectables se
sont revenus et qu'il considère alors
que sa mission est remplie ça on n'a pas
besoin
à paris et nous en avons parlé
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui en 2019 il y
avait le sommet du format normandie ou
dans des discussions compliquées avait
été formulée et validé par tous les
participants des mesures concrètes qui
doivent être prises
avant tout par les autorités de kiev
depuis rien n'a été fait et il ya un
grand nombre d'exemples où on voit que
la partie ukrainienne a rompu ses
engagements de cessez le feu et c'est
important pour nous de comprendre
clairement
[Musique]
qu'elle va être l'orientation concrètes
que nous allons suivre à tel ou tel
niveau et c'est le travail qui est menée
actuellement par les conseillers de
politique extérieure de l'ue fois ma
normandie et notre approche est
parfaitement clair est fondée
et transparente et nous espérons bien
que
la répétition que nous avons données de
ces principes ont été a été entendue à
berlin et à paris et que c'est les
autorités de berlin et paris forceront
amèneront les autorités de kiev à
respecter leurs engagements
et comme le président poutine l'a dit
plusieurs fois en tant que membres du
groupe de contact en tant que membre du
groupe 2 du format normandie nous allons
favoriser un accord pour voir
comment sont
respectés en pratique
les accords de minsk et ensuite concerne
les états unis ce sujet a souvent été
abordée avec l'administration précédente
celle de dieu monsieur trump
et le département d'état 20 représentant
spécial qui travaillaient avec
don sur le sujet de l'ukraine et qui
travaillait en parallèle aux réunions du
groupe de contact il y avait des
attitudes particulières sur ce qu'il
fallait mettre fin et ces opinions aller
directement en conflit avec ce qui est
stipulé dans les accords de minsk mais
cela ne nous regarde pas mais enfin de
nous avons l'impression que aujourd'hui
les autorités maintiennent ont une
vision plus concrète et plus
l'équilibré et je pense qu'elles sont
sensibles au fait qu'aujourd'hui le
statut spécifique du donbass est
important et je pense que quand cela ce
sera plus clair et quand c'est
responsabilité qui est un qui seront
attribués à lougansk de donetsk en vertu
des accords de minsk a ce moment la
situation sera plus simple est ce qui a
été
le jeu le souhait de kiev
pour de
d'entériner dans la loi les des
dispositions qui font que les velléités
de kiev de
lougansk et donetsk seront écartés et
j'espère que les discussions permettront
de trouver une solution est d'avoir un
rôle
et que les autorités occidentales ont
auront une influence bénéfique majeur
sur les autorités de kiev
[Musique]
faire en sorte que
la diffusion
entre autres existent mais par contre
nous avons que toujours
l'alliance nationale des journalistes
ils exigent le bloquer et rt nous
n'avons pratiquement pas la possibilité
de continuer notre travail si nous avons
eu des prix internationaux émis il n'y a
aucun autre pays où nous aurions autant
de problèmes à travailler qu'en
allemagne il ya aussi la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme
au milieu de laquelle elle le
gouvernement doit s'assurer l'accès
libre à l'information
et à la liberté d'opinion
on
espère à s'attendre à avoir le soutien
du gouvernement allemand
travaille en allemagne
diffuse son contenu via l'internet la
chaîne
c'est qui la voudrait quatrième chaîne
des médias sociaux d'une boule de stress
quand les journalistes ont toujours
l'accès aux conférences de presse et
est toujours présente dans le cadre
presque toutes les manifestations je
voir votre chaîne
n'était a partout et
ce n'est pas qu'il y ait cette
interférence de l'étape là nous avons
solution concernant la plateforme les
propriétaires de cette plateforme
youtube après la décision selon laquelle
il y a eu des violations des règles de
diffusion
cela n'a rien à voir avec le
gouvernement allemand et il n'ya pas
d'interférence du mouvement allemand
parce que ça aurait contredit notre
vision
sur la profonde on ne peut pas
s'attendre
soutien quelques temps
je l'attends pas mais je pense que
aujourd'hui sa sauce la mise en oeuvre
est en cours on nous en avons parlé en
détail aujourd'hui parce que à l'étape
préliminaire de cette situation complexe
j'avais invité
l'ambassadeur de la fédération de la
république fédérale d'allemagne
au ministère nous sommes préoccupés par
ce qui arrive à nos journalistes nous
avons des raisons de supposer que le
gouvernement allemand
a un lien direct avec ce qui se produit
je rappelle qu'à l'étape préliminaire
en fait il y avait le problème de
traitement
des comptes bancaires de nos
journalistes puisqu'il veut des il y
avait eu ensuite des signes d'optimisme
et puis ensuite il était de moins en
moins nombreux et les autorités
allemandes n'étaient pas d'accord pour
attribuer à rt 2 une une licence et rts
s'est adressé à ce moment là d'autres
pays et je pense que précisément berlin
a fait tout ce qui était possible pour
que cette autorisation ne soit pas
donnée également dans d'autres
au capital néanmoins la serbie a quand
même donné une
autorisation alors que ceux ci
les médias le régulateur des médias
allemands à bloquer donc
les la diffusion par satellite en
infraction avec les règles du
journalisme en europe et cela
ce n'est pas seulement à l'encontre de
la convention sur la diffusion mais
aussi en infraction a beaucoup de
conventions assez de l'unesco du conseil
de l'europe des accords de l'eau l'eau
sur
le fait qu' il n'est pas autorisé à
faire des obstacles à la diffusion des
médias et je pense que l'allemagne en
tant que signataire de ces différences
d'accord prendra les mesures qui ne
discriminent rompt pas la chaîne rte
dogs et nous voudrions que cette
situation soit résolue nous avons aucun
intérêt
avoir une réponse
symétrique mais pour l'instant nous
attendons
des mesures de la part de nos
partenaires allemande et je ne dis pas
quelles mesures doivent être prises
l'essentiel c'est que les journalistes
russes plus se sentir à l'aise et pas
discriminer et quand nos journalistes
ont une telle évaluation de la situation
et je pense que la solution sera trouvée
mais encore une fois nous ne voulons pas
créer deux
d'obstacles au journaliste allemand qui
opère en fédération de russie
mais s'il le faut ne seront peut-être
forcée
bien que nous ne le ferions pas ne sont
peut-être obligé de prendre des mesures
réciproques
voilà la situation telle qu'elle est
alors je propose qu'on finit sur quelque
chose note un peu plus réjouissante
interdiction
quatre
messages officiels
transmettre
avec lesquels vous cette venue ne sera
pas trop large
c'est tout
la liberté
qu'il ne peut pas
son prix d'efforts
on est clairement
l'intervention du gouvernement qu'il
s'agisse des états unis ou de la russie
donc nous avons des agences compétentes
qui s'occupent de toutes ces questions
c'est tout je vous remercie